Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in a learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good
嗨，我是马克斯（Max），是一名在西约克郡学习障碍服务部门工作的助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在稳步朝着那个看似不可能的目标——考取临床心理学博士学位——迈进。带着这个最终目标，我想了解一下目前的情况，看看有哪些书对此会有所帮助。我偶然看到了玛丽安（Marianne）的书《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并决定买下这本书来协助我的旅程，这对我来说是一个绝佳的决定。我发现玛丽安的书信息量极大，且极具启发性。我尤其喜欢书中的故事让我确信：成为一名心理学家并不需要学术成绩完美，只要你具备良好的
interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. Behind every best-selling psychology book is a story and a person. Today, we're hearing from Dr. Marta DeRos-Coyado. From her journey into clinical psychology to her passion for supporting families, Marta has built a career that bridges therapy, parenting and public psychology. In this very special episode, part of the 200 episode celebrations for the aspiring psychologist podcast, podcast. We'll explore what drew her into the field, what keeps her inspired and the lessons
人际交往能力，比如同情心和共情能力，你就一定能成功。我强烈建议所有有志成为心理学家的人阅读这本书，同时也推荐给那些想对临床心理学领域有更多了解、并因此萌生有一天在该领域工作愿望的人。在每一本畅销心理学书的背后，都有一个故事和一个人。今天，我们采访的是玛塔·德罗斯-科亚多（Marta DeRos-Coyado）博士。从她踏入临床心理学的旅程，到她对支持家庭的热情，玛塔建立了一个连接治疗、育儿和公共心理学的职业生涯。在这个非常特殊的节目中——它是“有志心理学家播客”（the aspiring psychologist podcast）200期庆祝活动的一部分——我们将探讨是什么吸引她进入这个领域，是什么让她保持灵感，以及
aspiring psychologists can take from her path. Hope you find it really useful. If you do, please like and subscribe for more. Hi, I just want to welcome back to the podcast, Dr. Martha. Welcome back. Thank you so much for being here. Hi, thanks for having me again. Well, you're so welcome and I wanted to really, I guess, as part of our 200 episode celebration of the aspiring psychologist podcast. Think a little bit about you because I think sometimes when you've got a big social following like you have on your Instagram account, people are like, oh, I'd like to be a psychologist or they're like, how did Dr. Marta get to be this psychologist that I see before before me? Could you tell us a little bit about your career? Yeah, I think, I mean, I fell into
有志心理学家可以从她的道路中吸取什么经验。希望你觉得这真的很有用。如果你觉得有帮助，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，我只想欢迎玛塔博士再次来到播客节目。欢迎回来。非常感谢你来到这里。嗨，谢谢你再次邀请我。不客气，作为我们“有志心理学家播客”200期庆祝活动的一部分，我想，呃，稍微谈谈你，因为我觉得有时候当你拥有像你的Instagram账号那样庞大的粉丝群体时，人们会想：哦，我想成为一名心理学家，或者他们会想：玛塔博士是怎么成为我眼前这位心理学家的呢？你能跟我们讲讲你的职业生涯吗？好的，我想，我是因为
psychology because my English teacher kind of suggested I should look into it, which I think is interesting. I don't know if anyone else has gone through that process, but you know, around 16, when you're trying to like think about what am I going to do with my future. We used to have, you know, careers, advisors or whatever they were called at my school. And I've talked about this with other of my friends. We've had such different experiences. But I, it was really interesting because I always wanted to work in medicine. I wanted to be a medical doctor. That was my calling, I felt. And then when I understood what it meant, which included surgery, I didn't want anything to do with it. So I'm not, I'm not into like, you know, cutting things off. You know, that was like, no,
英语老师建议我应该了解一下心理学，才误打误撞进入这个领域的，我觉得这挺有意思的。我不知道是不是还有其他人经历过这个过程，但你知道的，大约16岁时，当你试图思考“我将来要做什么”时。我们学校以前有那种职业顾问，或者管他们叫什么的人。我和其他朋友也讨论过这个。我们的经历太不相同了。但对我来说，这非常有趣，因为我一直想从事医学工作。我想成为一名内科医生。我觉得那是我的天职。然后，当我理解了这意味着什么——包括外科手术时——我便不想和它沾边了。所以我不喜欢，你知道的，切除东西之类的事情。当时觉得，不，
I don't think I can do it. Like, I just, I don't think I'm cut for that. Like, pun intended, not for me. So then I was kind of stuck because I was really into science. I loved English, but I was really into biology and chemistry. Like they were my thing. So I didn't really know what to do with myself. I think I felt quite lost. And my English teacher said to me, you think and speak like a psychologist.
我觉得我做不到。我是说，双关语，但这真的不适合我。所以当时我有点卡住了，因为我真的很喜欢科学。我喜欢英语，但我特别喜欢生物和化学。那是我的强项。所以我真的不知道自己该做什么。我觉得自己当时非常迷茫。我的英语老师对我说：“你的思考和说话方式就像一个心理学家。”
And we didn't have psychology at my school. It wasn't part of our curriculum. And I was like, I don't even know what they are. They're a bit weird. I remember having like a weird idea of like, especially in my school, you know, a shrink. Oh, God. I don't want to be one of those.
我们学校当时没有心理学这门课。它不是我们课程的一部分。当时我想：我甚至不知道心理学家是做什么的。他们有点怪。我记得当时对他们有一种奇怪的印象，尤其是在我们学校里，那种“心理医生”。天哪，我可不想成为那种人。
That sounds awful. And he was wonderful. a, you know, the power of teachers, I think, like definitely for me, something that influenced me. He then, you know, recommended I did some reading, so I did. I was then really interested when I realized that the core of psychology was that it was a science and I had no idea about it and that there was loads of areas, you know, really broad. And so I was really interested in things like forensics and addiction and definitely health. But like, you know, I had suddenly I was like, oh, I'm really interested in all these things, the brain.
听起来太糟糕了。但他真的很棒。啊，你知道老师的力量，我想，对我来说绝对是一种影响。然后他建议我读一些书，于是我读了。当我意识到心理学的核心是一门科学，而我之前对此一无所知，并且它有大量的领域，非常广泛时，我真的对它产生了兴趣。所以我对法医学、成瘾研究，尤其是健康领域非常感兴趣。但是，你知道的，我突然觉得：“哦，我对所有这些东西——大脑——都很感兴趣。”
I was like, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. This sounds great behavior. So I went to university. I picked a psychology course, and I also kind of had very good, which I think is helpful for young people. I had very good adults around me in my life who were very good at listening to me, very good at being curious with me.
我当时就想：哦，对，对，对。这听起来太棒了，关于行为的研究。于是我上了大学。我选修了心理学课程，而且我身边也有非常好的一些成年人——我认为这对年轻人很有帮助——他们非常擅长倾听我，非常擅长和我一起保持好奇心。
And basically, the message I gathered was do something you think you might enjoy. And if you don't, don't worry about it. you can do something else like honestly i went to university thinking okay this is like a because otherwise i was going to do biochemistry i was going to go pure science and i decided i'll try it because if i hate it i can still go off and do you know pure science because i will have some skills etc which i think was a really good message to give a young person this isn't like your final decision went to uni i loved it i like i never look back um I really thought I would end up in forensics because I loved it.
基本上，我得到的讯息是：去做一件你觉得可能会享受的事。如果你发现并不喜欢，也不用担心，你可以去做别的事。说实话，我去上大学时想的是：好吧，这就像是一个……因为如果我不选这个，我就要去做生物化学，我要去学纯科学。我决定尝试一下，因为如果我讨厌它，我仍然可以去从事，你知道的，纯科学，因为我会掌握一些技能等等。我认为这是一个给年轻人的非常好的讯息：这并非你的最终决定。我去了大学，我爱上了它，我从没有回过头。嗯……我真的以为我最后会从事法医学，因为我太喜欢它了。
And I actually really liked the idea of working in like, yeah, a prison. Sounds really weird, but it's true. But health won me over. I mean, my mom always says, how did you not know that? You wanted to be a medical doctor. I'm like, I don't know. I think I forgot. I think I forgot when I was in psychology that.
而且我实际上非常喜欢在监狱里工作那种想法。听起来真的很奇怪，但这是真的。不过健康心理学最终赢得了我的芳心。我的妈妈总是说：“你怎么会不知道？你以前不是想当医生吗？”我说：“我不知道。我想我忘了吧。我想我在学心理学的时候把那个给忘了。”
So I ended up in health. I ended up doing a master's in health sciences, which I absolutely loved. like health psychology. And then I became an assistant psychologist in pediatrics, which I only did about six months on because I got on the course. But I mean, that was it. I remember in that pediatric post being like, no, this is it. This is my calling. And at the time I was working in neurology, obviously under the supervision of a clinical psychologist, I was just an assistant, working with children with epilepsy and children had brain injuries. And they also had brain surgeries. It was like fascinating. I loved it. So I went into doctoral training with like
所以我最后进入了健康领域。我攻读了健康科学硕士学位，我真的非常喜欢它，比如健康心理学。然后我成了一名儿科助理心理学家，这份工作我只做了大约六个月，因为我考上了博士课程。但我的意思是，就是这样。我记得在那个儿科岗位上时，我就觉得：不，就是这个，这就是我的天职。当时我在神经病学部门工作，显然是在一位临床心理学家的监督下，我只是一个助理，和患有癫痫和脑损伤的儿童一起工作。他们还做过脑部手术。这太迷人了我太喜欢了。所以我带着
my mind absolutely focused on pediatrics. But it was really interesting because genuinely every single placement I went on in training, I loved. And I was so shocked. So I did psychodynamic for a year in my first year, which I think is rare, very rare. And I remember being angry because all my everybody else on my course apart from three of us and they're two of my best friends how interesting is that still now everybody else went on a CBT placement but I did not and I remember feeling rejected you know how you feel like oh I'm not a good fit why would that why me anyway it was meant to be a six month placement and then they kept the three of us for a full year which they've never done before again I think that's quite telling because the three of us
绝对专注于儿科的心态进入了博士培训。但非常有趣的是，我在培训期间经历的每一个实习岗位，我都非常喜欢。这让我感到非常震惊。所以在第一年，我做了一年的心理动力学实习，我认为这很少见，非常罕见。我记得当时我很生气，因为我们班除了我们三个人之外——其中有两个人现在还是我最好的朋友，这多有趣啊——其他所有人都去做了CBT（认知行为疗法）实习，而我没有。我当时感到被拒绝了，你知道那种感觉吗？就像“我不适合吗？为什么偏偏是我？为什么是我？”不管怎样，这本来注定是一项为期六个月的实习，然后他们把我们三个人留了整整一年，这在以前从来没有过。再次说明，我觉得这很能说明问题，因为我们三个人
loved it and I think the three of us now work we all work with children that was an adult placement but we've all kept something I believe it I think that that year changed us the most or changed me the most for sure I learned skills and therapy that I don't think I would have learned anywhere else if I hadn't done psychodynamic you know therapy the way that I did I loved it I remember thinking this is it this is what I'm going to do for life and then obviously I had my My child placement was very CBT. CBT is not my calling. And it was so interesting to be like, oh yeah, this is not for me.
都非常喜欢它，而且我觉得我们三个人现在都在工作，我们都和儿童一起工作——那其实是一个成人实习岗位，但我们都保留了一些东西，我相信这一点。我认为那一年对我们的改变最大，或者对我的改变绝对是最大的。我学到了在其他地方绝对学不到的治疗技能，如果我没有以那种方式进行心理动力学治疗的话。我太喜欢了。我记得当时想：就是这个，这就是我一生活跃的领域。然后显然我有了……我的儿童实习岗位非常偏向CBT。CBT不是我的天职。很有趣的是，当时我意识到：“哦，对的，这不适合我。”
But I loved it. I loved the kids, I loved the families. And then anyway, roll on to my third year, I asked for a pediatric placement. And I did, I had to be interviewed for it. It was at UCLA, and there was like loads of, you know, people from different courses being interviewed for it. And somehow, God knows why. they chose me, and I'm so grateful for it because it was the best year of my life.
但我依然很喜欢它。我喜欢那些孩子，我喜欢那些家庭。然后，时间快进到我的第三年，我申请了一个儿科实习岗位。我为此接受了面试。那是在加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA），有好多来自不同课程的人都在接受面试。不知怎么的，天知道为什么，他们选中了我。我对此感激不尽，因为那是我一生中最美好的一年。
I still think that those psychologists were so inspiring. I think that first year and that third year really cushioned something in who I am as a clinical psychologist, like my values, what I focus on, what I reflect on, what I think about. I'm still very much inspired by the psychologists I work with. I think they're amazing, but that I felt it was transformative for me and it very much became like, this is it. I knew this was what I wanted to do. And suddenly I had this insight into family therapy. So family therapy was, I don't know if they still do, fingers crossed they still do. Because it's a long, I trained a long time ago, but they used to embed family
我依然觉得那些心理学家太鼓舞人心了。我认为第一年和第三年真的沉淀了我作为一名临床心理学家的核心特质，比如我的价值观、我关注的重点、我反思的内容、我的思考方式。我至今仍然深受共事的心理学家的启发。我觉得他们太了不起了。我感到这段经历对我来说是变革性的，它非常明确地变成了：“就是这个。我知道这就是我想做的事。”突然之间，我对家庭治疗有了这种深刻的理解。所以家庭治疗——我不知道他们现在是否还在这样做，祈祷他们还在这样做吧，因为时间很久远了，我接受培训是很久以前的事了，但他们过去会在病房里融入家庭治疗。那太美妙了。所以我后来接受了家庭治疗的培训，因为那就是我想成为的……那就是我想成为的人。感觉就像是……有趣的是，对我来说，其中有很多心理动力学思想。比如，你知道的，有很多融合。在很多模式中都有很多融合。但对我来说，心理动力学和家庭治疗融合成为了我。它们塑造了我。它们塑造了我对心理健康的思考方式。
therapy in the ward. It was beautiful. And so I trained in family therapy afterwards because because that's who I wanted, you know, that's what I wanted to be. It felt like, and interestingly, there's a lot, for me, there's some psychodynamic ideas. Like, you know, there's lots of blending. There's lots of blending in lots of models. But for me, the psychodynamic and the family therapy kind of became me. They shaped me. They shape how I think about mental health.
它们塑造了我对问题和问题行为的思考方式，以及我思考在治疗中如何与家庭和儿童互动的模式。它们也塑造了我对周围人互动的思考方式。所以我觉得那真的塑造了我。但最终，随着时间的推移，毫无疑问，是我共事过的孩子们和家庭塑造了我最多。我在很多儿科服务机构工作过，所有的服务对象都是慢性健康状况、危及生命、缩短寿命的疾病。我想这是我的天职所在。我想如果我有一天重返英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS），那一定还是去那里。毫无疑问。
They shaped how I think about problems and problem behaviors and how I think about my interaction in therapy with families and children. They shaped how I think about my interactions with people around me as well. So I think that really shaped me. But ultimately, over time, without a doubt, it's the kids and the families that I've worked with, that I've shaped me the most. I have worked in so many, all my pediatric services have been chronic health, life limiting, life shortening conditions. It's what I have a calling for, I think. And I think if I ever go back into the NHS, that's where I'm going. There's no doubt.
但我认为教会我最多的还是孩子们和家庭。我认为，就知识、实践和技能而言，培训是如此无价。我想念它。我想念拥有现场督导，我在第三年因为学习家庭治疗而拥有过这种督导。但我怀念那种针对每一个个案的、非常深入的、深思熟虑的督导。就像当你获得资格认证后，突然手头有50个个案、80个个案，你会想：天哪，我不可能把所有这些都拿出来讨论。你知道，那太不一样的了。你知道，在NHS的工作生活与我在培训期间得到的充满滋养的环境截然不同——对我个人而言，我的培训体验是这样的。我很怀念那个。
But I think it's the kids and the families that have taught me the most. I think, you know, training was so invaluable in terms of the knowledge and the practice and the skill. And I think I miss it. I miss having live supervision, which is what I had in my third year because of family therapy. But I miss having that kind of very deep, very thoughtful supervision about every single case. Like when you qualify and you suddenly have 50 cases, 80 cases, and you're like, oh my God, I can't talk about all of them. You know, that it's so different. You know, the working NHS life is so different from the very nurturing for me, anyway, my personal experience of training. And I missed that.
我真的很怀念那个。我也怀念能够投入足够的、充满情感和思考的时间。所以我觉得说出这些……并不让我感到意外，当我在谈论时进行反思，我最终选择离开NHS，尽管是在很长一段时间之后——我全职工作了，我的意思是，获得资格后，我全职工作了12年才离开。所以这是一段很长的时间。但当我选择离开时，我现在唯一紧紧抓住的就是知识和技能。我认为在NHS工作是如此无价，用我的一位同事经常说的一个词来说，但
I definitely missed that. I also missed being able to give enough emotional, thoughtful time. So I think saying this kind of also... doesn't surprise me, reflecting on it as I'm talking, that I've ended up leaving the NHS, but after a long time, like I worked full time for, I mean, post-qualification, I worked full time for 12 years before I, like, left. So it's a long time. But when I chose to leave, the one thing that I now have held on to is the knowledge, the skills. I think working in the NHS is so invaluable for, it's a word that one of my colleagues used all the time, but
她是正确的，那就是巩固你的技能，并真正让你意识到保障儿童安全、风险以及诸如此类的问题——如果你不在那种环境中工作，有时你可能会对这些视而不见。对此我非常感激，因为我觉得我可以掌握这些知识，掌握这些技能。但我也能够做我在培训期间最喜欢的事情，那就是以一种更加滋养的方式，向我所负责的家庭提供我的思考和情感空间，因为我不再手头带着50个个案了。我非常谨慎地对待自己能够承担多少家庭的支持工作，而一旦我承担了，我就会把他们照顾好。我认为让我能够做到这一点的是，我有一位以前在NHS指导过我的督导。所以，你知道，我……
she was right, consolidating your skills and really making you aware of like safeguarding and risk and, you know, issues that sometimes I think you might be blind to if you don't work in that environment. And I am so grateful for that because I feel like I can hold on to that knowledge and hold on to those skills. But I can also now do the thing I loved during training, which is offer my thought, emotional space in a much more nurturing way to the families I do hold because I don't hold 50 cases. I'm very careful about how many families I feel able to hold, and when I hold them, I hold them well. And I think what's allowed me to do that is having a supervisor who used to supervise me in the NHS. So, you know, I've,
我觉得当你工作了很长时间，你显然会建立起各种关系。你可以保持，我一直和他们保持着联系，这让我感到踏实。而且我认为，是的，只要把培训中的技能和知识巩固到实践中，然后告诉自己：“我是一个人了，但我并不感到孤单。我觉得，你知道，所有那些年，我把它们像背包一样随身携带。它们一直和我在一起。”我想有了我的督导，我们曾在NHS一起工作过，我的私人督导。这真的很有帮助，因为我们经常反思那些……你知道的，我们一起经历过的事情，或者我们在那种环境中经历过的事情。所以，是的，这就是我如何走到这里的。我不知道还能说些什么。我想我只是想对你刚才所说的话做出回应。这确实是一种特权，不是吗？当你能与那些让你感到焕发光彩的任何客户群体一起做这项工作时，这……我不知道，这很难形容。就像今天早上我的孩子们对我说：“哦，你要去无聊的老工作岗位了。”而我说：“我要去工作，但它一点也不无聊。我热爱它。”
I think when you work for so long, you build, obviously, relationships. You can hold, I've held on to them, and that grounds me. And I think, yeah, just consolidating the skills and the knowledge from training into practice and then being like, I'm on my own, but I don't feel on my own. I feel like, you know, all those years, I kind of carry them like a bit like a backpack. They're with me all the time. And I think with my supervisor, we've worked together in the NHS, my private supervisor. it really helps because we often reflect on things that, you know, we've experienced together
你知道的，我想让他们知道，实际上当我……当我……当我在办公室里，当我在工作时，我并不是在刻苦煎熬，我真的很享受其中。这是可以通过你的工作做到的，你不仅仅是为了……你不仅仅是为了赚钱而活着。百分之百是的。当离开NHS时，人们当时问我：“如果你不干这个，你会做什么？”我说：“我觉得我不会做别的了。我热爱我的工作。”
or we've experienced in that setting. So, yeah, so that's how I've landed here. I don't know what else to say. I guess I just wanted to react to what you'd said. Well, it really is a privilege, isn't it? When you get to do this work with, with whatever client group it is that lights you up, it's, I don't know, it's difficult to describe. Like my kids this morning said to me, oh, you're going off to boring old work. And I went, I'm going to work, but it's not boring. I love it. you know and i want them to know that actually when i'm when i'm when i'm in my office when i'm working i'm not like at the grindstone i'm really enjoying that and that is possible from your work and you don't just have to you don't just have to live live to earn your money a hundred
我知道并非每个心理学家都这样。但我热爱这种多样性。我喜欢这里从来没有沉闷的时刻。我喜欢听人们的故事。我喜欢故事。我是说，英语老师，形成了一个完整的闭环。
percent and when i left the NHS and people asked me on the time what would you do if you didn't do this and i was like i don't think i would do anything else like i i love my work And I know that's not true for every psychologist. But I love the variety. I love that there's never a dull moment. I love hearing people's stories. I love stories. I mean, English teacher, full circle.
但这确实是真的。我喜欢故事。我喜欢见证别人的故事。我认为这是一种荣誉和特权。人们的故事有时会塑造我对自己的故事的看法，或者塑造我对别人故事的看法。你知道，我觉得它们最终都交织在了一起，在某个地方编织在了一起。
But it's true. I love stories. And I love being witnessed to people's stories. I think that's an honour and a privilege. And people's stories sometimes shape how I think about my own stories or how I think about somebody else's stories. You know, I feel like they all end up interconnected, They didn't weave somewhere.
我认为和一个房间里的人坐在一起，谈论他们可能从未与任何人分享过的事情，是如此荣幸。我想，你知道的，如果我不热爱它，我就不会做我现在做的事，因为这很难。它也可能在情感上极其消耗精力。它会占用你大量的思考时间和情感容量，
I think it is such an honor to sit in a room with someone and talk about things that maybe they've never shared with anybody else. I think, you know, I wouldn't do what I do if I didn't love it because it's hard. Like, it can also be incredibly emotionally draining. It can take up a lot of your thinking time, a lot of your emotional capacity,
特别是如果你是一位父母，并且有自己的孩子。我想这也是为什么我也感到非常荣幸，因为我现在可以私下里做这件事，我可以像我说的，为自己设定非常健康的界限，确定多少人是健康的，特别是当我有一个小不点的时候——因为我有一个年幼的孩子——我需要把情感空间留给她，而且我意识到如果把所有精力都投入到治疗室里，当我回到家时就什么都不剩了。我想我在没有孩子的时候可以做到这一点，但我现在做不到了。这就是我真正意识到的事情——实际上，为了做好临床工作，同时也为了成为我想象中那样的好妈妈，我也需要照顾好自己。我认为这很重要，不仅要找到工作时间的平衡，还要找到你所做的工作类型的平衡。我认为，你知道的，有些个案在情感上会占用更多的空间，比如思考空间，所有这些事情，比其他个案要多得多。所以认清你的极限在哪里，以及如何通过督导、通过拥有诸如运动之类的策略来保护自己，这真的很重要。所以我喜欢瑜伽。我总是在树林里散步。
especially if you're a parent and you've got children. And I think that's why I also feel very privileged that I can do this privately, now and I can kind of, like I said, kind of, you know, set really healthy limits for myself about how many people is healthy, particularly while I've got a tiny little one because I've got a young child because I need my emotional space for her and I'm aware that if it all goes into like the therapy room, I have nothing left when I come home. And I think I could do that when I didn't have children, but I can't do that anymore. Like that's something I became really
我给自己养了一只狗。他就像我的治疗犬一样，因为我必须每天带他去散步。这真的很有帮助。它帮助我的大脑和身体从工作中抽离出来，得到放松。我们走进大自然。我们走进树林。我们去公园。突然间，你知道的，我回到家时就会感觉好多了。
aware of that actually I need to look after me too in order to do good work clinically but also in order to be the mum I want to be to my kids. I think that's important like finding your balance as well not just in hours of working but the type of work that you do. I think you know some cases will take up a lot more space emotionally, you know, thinking space, all of that stuff than others. So I think it is important learning where is your limit and how do you protect yourself as well through supervision, through having strategies like exercising. So I love yoga. I always walk in the woods.
他确实是我的治疗犬，千真万确。他是一只猎鹬犬。所以，他……但他对我很完美。他的精力和他的状态完全是我所需要的，能给我带来喘息，给我带来释放。所以当我接孩子放学时，我正处于妈妈模式，而不是仍然处于工作模式。我认为所有这些事情对学习来说都非常重要。确实如此。谢谢你分享你关于自我照顾小仪式的这些看法，这听起来真的很重要。
I got myself a dog. And he's like my therapy dog because I have to take him for a walk every day. And that is helpful. It helps my brain and my body disconnect from work, relax. And we go into nature. We go into the woods. Are we going to Parklands? And suddenly, you know, like, I just feel better when I get back into the house.
但在我们按下录音键之前，你曾谈到过尝试申请助理心理学家职位的经历，你说：“我申请了80个工作岗位，甚至连面试机会都没有得到。”这并不总是那么容易，不是吗？这些工作并不总是垂手可得。所以，如果有人觉得“什么时候才能轮到我？这会有结果吗？有什么意义？”这就是意义所在，你知道的，我们都是合格的心理学家，我们都曾为获得AP（助理心理学家）职位而苦苦挣扎，我们最终都经历了一次幸运的机缘巧合，这意味着我们在面试中获得了第二名，但最终得到了这份工作。我们俩都有这种共同的经历，这改变了我们俩的格局。是的，我觉得这真的很重要，我想对我来说，要……嗯，有几件事，但如果你真的
And he is my therapy dog, like fact. He's a gun dog. So he's, but he is perfect for me. Like, his energy and how he is is absolutely what I need to give me that break, to give me that release. So then when I do school pickup, I'm in mum mode rather than still in work mode. I think all those things are really important to learn. It really is. thanks for sharing that about your little kind of self-care rituals that sounds really important
想要它，我觉得就坚持下去。不要根据你是否通过面试来定义自己的价值。大多数时候这只是运气。这并不意味着你做不好。你看你，再看看我。我想人们可能会在Instagram上看到我，然后说：“天哪，她有这么多的粉丝。”我说：“是的，但这并不重要。”说实话，这真的不重要。我觉得找一份助理的工作几乎快把我折磨崩溃了。我也曾问过自己：“我该做这个吗？”我坚持了下来，因为我觉得这就是我想做的事，
but before we hit record you were kind of talking about the experience of trying to apply for an assistant psych role and you said i applied for 80 jobs i didn't even get interviews like it's not always it's not always easy is it these jobs don't always come to you and so if anyone is feeling like when will it come well will it come what's the point this is the point you know we are both qualified psychs we've both struggled to get AP roles we both had a lucky chance eventually that meant that we got second in an interview but then ended up getting the job and that we both shared that as a kind of mutual experience and that change the game for us both yeah i think it's really important to kind of i guess for me it's too to well there's a couple of things but if you really
所以我不会放弃。我甚至还做过——我甚至不知道他们现在是否还这样做。我真心希望他们不要再这样了，因为我觉得这不合适。我要用这个词。这可能有点太严重了。请不要恨我。
want it, I think just keep going. And don't define your worth on whether or not you get through an interview. It's luck most of the time. It doesn't mean you're not going to be good at it. You know, look at you, look at me. And I guess people might see me on Instagram and be like, oh my gosh, she's got all these followers. I'm like, yeah, but that doesn't matter. Like, honestly, that doesn't matter. I think getting an assistant job nearly broke me. And I did ask myself, should I do this? I carried on because I was like, I feel like this is what I want to do,
我觉得这有点近乎剥削，它把目标对准了那些想要进入我们行业的脆弱年轻人。但在我得到助理工作之前，我曾做过无薪志愿岗位。我很确定这就是我最终得到助理工作的原因。但我没有得到一分钱的报酬，却要工作满额时间。我觉得这不对劲。
so I'm not going to give up. And I even worked, I don't even know if they do this anymore. I really hope they don't, because I don't think it's appropriate. I'm going to use this word. It might be too big. Please don't hate me.
我想把它公之于世。我觉得这不对劲，因为我当时为了赚钱还得去做其他工作，否则我怎么在伦敦生存下去？所以我想，你知道的，我觉得这太不公平了。我认为我们应该尊重这样一个事实：那些想要加入像我们这样行业的年轻人通常都非常努力、非常敬业、对他们想做的事情非常坚定。因为，我的意思是，我现在就要说出来：对我来说，NHS是一份充满职业使命感的工作。你不会成为千万富翁。人们在NHS工作不是为了这个。
I think it's slightly abusive and it targets vulnerable young people who want to get into our profession. But I worked in honorary posts before I got my assistant job. I'm pretty sure that's how I ended up getting an assistant job. But I didn't get paid a penny and I worked full hours. I don't think that's okay.
人们在NHS工作是因为他们想去帮助别人，他们充满关怀。百分之百是这样。我从来没有在NHS遇到过哪个同事会说：“我是为了钱才干这个的。”如果你为了钱，你会去银行工作，或者去大公司工作，你不会为NHS工作。所以，是的，如果这是你的天职，请坚持下去，继续前进。不要把“你得了第二名”或者“你没能成功”当成是失败。你没有失败，那天只是面试你的某个人表现得比你更好而已。但总有一天，那个人会是你。不过另一方面，如果你到了那种觉得“这快把我压垮了”的程度，一定要考虑一下别的选择。心理学也不是世界上最好的东西，这其实是我最想表达的。尽管我说了那么多我有多热爱它，但这并不意味着它是你唯一能做的工作。所以，我有一个朋友考上了博士课程，他非常可爱。我觉得他在治疗室里一定会表现得难以置信地出色。我虽然从未和他一起在治疗室共事过，但这只是我的想象，但他退学了。
Like I'm putting it out there into the world. I don't think that's okay because I then had to work in other jobs to get money because how else was I going to survive in London? So I think, you know, I think it's really unfair. I think we need to honour the fact that young people who, want to join a profession like ours are usually very hard working, very dedicated, very committed to what they want to do. Because, I mean, I'm going to say it now, but to me, the NHS is a vocational job. You're not going to be a multimillionaire. That's not why people
这听起来可能很残酷，但我认为他有勇气说出：“这份工作不适合我。”他是一名社会工作者。他只是说：“这不适合我。我知道我来到了这里。我知道我为来到这里付出了很多努力。但你猜怎么着？这不是我想要的。”承认“我尝试过，我也努力过，但我觉得有别的东西才是我的天职”，这需要勇气。外面的世界有太多不同的事物了。你知道的，还有很多其他的工作你可以做，它们仍然可以与心理学相关，或者与心理学并行。你并没有
work in the NHS. People work in the NHS because they want to help and they care. Like, 100%. I have never met somebody in the NHS who's like, I'm in this for the money. You go work in a bank or you go and work for a big business you don't work for the NHS so yeah i think if this is your calling persevere keep going do not take any kind of you came second or you didn't make it as i'm a failure you're not somebody on that day just did a better job than you but one day it's going to be you but also too if you get to the point of going oh this is like breaking me definitely think about something else. Psychology is not the best thing in the world either, is kind of what I want to say. Even despite everything I've said, because I love it, it doesn't mean it's the only
低人一等。我讨厌这种想法。对我来说，他们都是我的同事。没有什么高人一等或低人一等之分。绝对没有。我知道NHS存在官僚等级制度，但你在与人交往的方式上不必遵循那一套。你与人建立连接的方式，他们与人共事的方式。对我来说，在NHS的多学科团队中工作是最美好的事情之一，这也是我现在最怀念的。百分之千。毫无疑问。那是我的团队。理疗师、言语治疗师、营养师、医生，我想念他们所有人。我们每个人都带来了不同的知识、不同的经验、对一个家庭不同的深刻见解，而大家聚在一起，就呈现出了一幅如此丰富多彩的画面。所以，如果你遇到了瓶颈，觉得“我没有在前进，我一直在尝试，我真的在苦苦挣扎”，那么请真心实意地思考：在这幅画面中，我还能在哪里找到适合我的位置？
job you can do. So I've got a friend who got on the course and he was so lovely. I think he would have been incredible in a therapy room. I was ever in a therapy room with him, but it's in my imagination and he quit. And that might sound like really harsh, but I think he had the courage to say, say, this job is not for me. And he's a social worker. He just said, this isn't for me. I know I got here. I know I worked hard to get here. Guess what? It's not what I want. That takes courage to kind of say, I've tried and I've worked hard, but there's something else I think is my calling. And there are so many different things out there. You know, so many other jobs that you can do that can still be, you know, psychology related or working alongside. And you're not.
哪里还能给我带来快乐？哪里能让我依然从心理学中获得我想要的东西，但却是在一个不同的职业中？因为那个职业可能正适合你。它可能不是你的第二选择，它实际上可能才是正确的选择。我相信这一点。我真的相信这一点。除了我刚才提到的那个朋友之外，我还有其他人的经历，他们正是这样做的——先是成为了心理学家，然后重新接受培训，成为了理疗师和职业治疗师，并感叹：“这才是我想做的事。”但正是因为他们先成为了一名心理学家，才让他们意识到原来那是他们真正想要的工作。所以，你知道，这没关系。
Not less than. I hate that idea. To me, they're all my colleagues. There's no like more than less than. Absolutely not. And I know the NHS lives on a hierarchy, but you don't have to follow it like in the way that you relate to people. You connect with people, the way they work with people. For me, working in a multidisciplinary team in the NHS was one of the most beautiful things and it is the biggest thing that I miss now. A thousand percent. No doubt about it. It's my team. The physios, the speech therapist, the dietitians, the doctors, I miss them all. We all brought different knowledge, different experiences, different, you know, insights about one family and together just brought such a rich picture. So if you're stuck and you think I'm not moving
改变主意是没问题的。你花在申请工作、做助理或无论什么事情上的时间并没有被浪费。我总是听到这种说法，年轻人说：“我不能浪费我过去的五年。”它们没有被浪费。你获得了技能。你获得了知识。你拥有了大量的经验。你可以把它们重新包装成不同的形状，然后带着这些继续前进。这是一个如此重要的信息。非常感谢你分享这些。我知道这会给许多人带来真正的安慰和启发。在结束之前，能跟我们讲讲你的两本书吗？它们已经出版了，我们可以在哪里买到？我的第一本畅销书——那是两年前的畅销书——叫做《如何成为成年人》（How to Be the Grown Up）。这是一本育儿书，对我来说带有一点点不一样的转折，因为它是关于提供心理学方面的
forward and I've been trying and I'm really struggling, genuinely think where else would I fit in this picture? else would bring me joy, where else, you know, but I still get the things I want to get from psychology, but in a different profession. Because that profession might be just right for you. It might not be your second choice. It might actually have been the right choice. Like I believe that. I really believe that. And I have more than that friend that I talked about, I have other experiences of people who've done exactly that, become psychologists and then retrained and become physios and OTs and gone, this is what I wanted to do. But it's taken them becoming a psychologist to realize it's that job that I wanted. So, you know, it's okay. It's
知识，涉及儿童发展、大脑发展，你知道的，那些我认为应该成为常识但并非如此的事情。那些我认为应该在学校里教但并没有教的事情。并以一种工具包的形式将它们包装起来。所以你可以，你知道的，翻到你想看的章节，谈论性、谈论死亡、思考离异，无论是什么。然后找到策略、想法，所有这些都基于心理学理论和知识。
okay to change your mind. The time you've spent applying for jobs or working as an assistant or whatever it is is not wasted. I hear that all the time. Young people going, I can't waste the last five years of mine. They're not wasted. You've got skills. You've got knowledge. You've got tons of experience. You can repackage it in a different shape and, you know, move forward with that. There's such an important message. Thank you so much for sharing that. I know that's going to be real comfort and food for thought for so many people. Just before we finish, could you tell us about your two books, which you have available and where we can get those? So my first book, which was a bestseller two years ago, is called How to Be the Grown Up. And it's a parenting book with a bit of a twist for me because it's about offering psychological,
我有很多临床经验也在其中。通过与家庭合作而形成的许多想法都在里面。
knowledge on child development, brain development, you know, things that I feel should be general knowledge but are not. Things that I feel should probably be taught in schools, but they're not. And offering packaging it in a way that is kind of like a toolkit. So you can, you know, flick to the chapter that you want to look at, talking about sex, talking about death, you know, thinking about separation, whatever it is. And find strategies, ideas, all based on psychological theory and knowledge. and a lot of my clinical experience is in there. Lots of ideas that have been shaped through working with families are in there.
所以其中一些可能不是经过科学证实的理论，但它们是我在治疗室里用过并且经常使用的东西。我把它们重新打包，献给父母、家庭、祖父母和老师。希望这能作为一个基础工具包，从照顾小宝宝一直到应对青少年。然后我的最后一章，
So some of them might not be like proved science, but they're things I've used in the therapy room and I use a lot of. And I've kind of repackaged them for parents, for families, for grandparents, for teachers. So hopefully that's useful as a kind of foundation from chilled little ones up to like teenage. And then my last chapter,
我稍微谈到了成年子女，因为我觉得我想触及这个话题，也就是当你的孩子长大成人后，你可能想与他们维持的关系。我的第二本书将于8月28日出版，当这个播客上线时可能已经出版了，书名叫《智能手机解决方案》（The Smartphone Solution）。能够写这本书让我感到非常荣幸，
I slightly talk about adult children because I feel like I wanted to touch on that like when your kids become grown-ups, the relationship you might want to maintain with them. And my second book, which comes out on the 28th of August, probably will have come out when this podcast goes out, is called The Smart Phone Solution. And it feels like a big privilege to have written this book
因为我写它是为了用一种不同的工具包和一系列想法来支持父母，去应对围绕着我们的、关于智能手机的恐惧，以及我们该如何将手机提供给孩子、何时提供给孩子，或者我们是否应该直接禁用它们。相反，我希望做的是为你提供一些科学依据，而且我对这些科学依据持批判态度，因为我认为这很重要。但愿这能为你建立意识，以便你能为你和孩子们做出健康的抉择，并有望将其作为健康的习惯融入你的家庭中。
because I wrote it to support parents with a different kind of toolkit and set of ideas around the fear that surrounds us with smartphones and how we offer them to our children, when we offer them to our children, should we just ban them? And instead, hopefully what I do is offer you some of the science, and I am critical of it because I think that's important. But hopefully builds awareness for you so that you can make healthy choices for you and your kids and hopefully embed them as healthy habits in your home.
通过我所说的“家庭手机誓约”（family phone pledge）。所以你们所有人都在其中。你们都在许下承诺。誓约是一个承诺，而不是一份合同。你们都在承诺，家里最重要的部分是聚在一起，而不是把手机带在身边。我认为从这个出发点开始，你可以开始做一些微小的调整，这可能会让你作为父母对自己的手机使用感觉更好，而且我也希望，能让你对孩子用手机做什么感到掌控自如、充满力量。太棒了。非常感谢。人们在哪里可以在Instagram上关注你？给我们你的Instagram账号。是Dr. Marta, psychologist。是的，我的名字拼写是Martha，因为我爸爸觉得，
through what I call the family phone pledge. So you're all in it together. You're all promising. A pledge is a promise, not a contract. You're all promising that the most important part in your home is being together, not having your phone on you. And I think from that place, you can start to make small tweaks that might make you as a parent feel better about your phone usage, but also, I'm hoping, in control and empowered of what your child gets to do with their phone. Amazing. Thank you so much. And where can people follow you on Instagram? Give us your Instagram handle. It's Dr. Marta, psychologist. And yeah, my name is spelt Martha because my dad thought,
哦，带一个不发音的h会很有趣，他当时并没有意识到我有一天会说英语。好的。太棒了。而且你，你知道的，我们在心理学中讨论咨询，对吧？这就是你在你的书中所做的事情，你以咨询模式提供你的知识，以便它能够接触到更广泛的受众。甚至包括你今天花时间与我的受众交谈——“有志心理学家播客”，你知道的，我们非常感谢你抽出时间，你拥有，你知道的，如此多的充满智慧的话语。所以谢谢你所做的一切。请继续做你正在做的事，并祝你的第二本书及未来的创作一切顺利。谢谢。和你聊天很愉快。非常感谢。也谢谢你。再次非常感谢玛塔·德罗斯-科亚多博士抽出时间。非常享受我们的聊天，我们
oh, a silent age would be so interesting, not realising I'd speak English one day. Okay. Amazing. And you are, you know, we talk about consultation in psychology, don't we? This is what you're doing with your books, you're offering your knowledge in a consultation model so that it reaches a wider audience. And even even your time in speaking to my audience today, the aspiring psych podcast, you know, we're so grateful for your time and you've got, you know, so many wise words. So thank you for doing what you do. Keep doing what you do and wishing you the very best of luck with your second books and beyond. Thank you. It's been lovely talking to you. Thank you so much. you too. Thank you again so much for Dr. Marta de Roscoiardo's time. Really enjoyed our chat and we
聊了好几个小时。我们只是把其中的一部分剪辑给你们听。我们其实可以把所有的开场闲聊也都录下来，那也会非常有趣。也许有一天我会做一个幕后花絮，你们就能听到那些我们只是在，你知道的，随性闲聊的部分了。如果在评论区告诉我你们觉得那样也会有帮助的话，我会很高兴的。非常感谢大家来到这里。说实话，作为200期庆祝活动的一部分，你们喜欢我们所做的事情，并且对播客说出如此可爱的话，这对我来说意义重大。你知道的，这是一项充满爱心的工作。确实如此，但我真的很热爱它。你们也帮助我保持责任感，因为如你们所知，这是一档每周播客，而且你知道的，播客就像是
we chatted for hours. We just we just gave you those bits. We probably could have recorded all the intro chat as well and that would have been really interesting. Maybe one day I'll do a behind the scenes and you'll get to listen into the bits where yeah we're just you know shooting the breeze. Let me know in the comments if you'd find that helpful too. Thank you. so much for being here. Honestly, part of this 200th episode celebration. It means the world to me that you guys like what we do and that you say such lovely things about the podcast. You know, it's a labour of love. It really is, but I do love it. And you guys help keep me accountable as well because, as you know, it's a weekly podcast and, you know, podcasts are
饥饿的猛兽，而且全是我自己自掏腰包一个人完成的。所以非常感谢你们的到来和收听。请务必点赞并订阅。如果你在YouTube上观看，请给我留个评论，你也可以在Spotify上的节目下方留言。我向你保证，无论我在哪里看到评论，我都会回复收到的每一条评论。所以，是的，请不要吝啬。如果你喜欢什么，请告诉我。如果你不喜欢什么，也请告诉我。现在花一点时间分享一些我收到的关于播客的美丽反馈。在YouTube上，卡洛琳·奥利里（Caroline O'Leary）谈到了通过心理学获得的新身份——从警察到培训，与克莱尔·邓恩（Claire Dunn）有同等的洞察力。这非常有趣且鼓舞人心。我很想听到
hungry beasts and I do it all myself at my own expense too. So thank you for for sure. showing up for listening. Please do like and subscribe. Please do drop me a comment if you're watching on YouTube and you can also comment on episodes on Spotify too. I promise you I respond to every comment I receive wherever I see them. So yeah, please don't be a stranger. If you love something, let me know. If you don't like something, let me know too. So let me take a moment to share some of the lovely feedback that I've been receiving about the podcast. Over on YouTube, we had Caroline O'Leary about the new identity through psychology, the police officer to training equal insight with Claire Dunn. This was very interesting and inspiring. I would love to hear
更多这样非常规的故事。所以非常感谢你的评论，卡洛琳，也谢谢你的观看。对于你，亲爱的听众和观众，你也会觉得这有帮助吗？请在评论区告诉我。在我和杰克（Jack）合作的那期关于职业塑造（job crafting）以及如何充分利用非心理学经验的节目中，凯瑟琳·基（Catherine Key）留下了可爱的评论：“职业塑造是一个非常实用的概念。作为一名正在考虑彻底改变职业方向进入心理学领域的人，这是反思我现有的工作经验并以全新视角高光呈现我相关技能给潜在雇主的完美灵感。谢谢杰克和玛丽安向我介绍了一种非常有帮助的促进职业转型的新方法。”
more non-conventional stories like this. So thank you so much for your comment, Caroline, and for watching. And to you, dear listener and dear watcher, would you find that helpful as well? Do let me know in the comments. And on the episode I did with Jack about kind of job crafting and making the most of your non-psychology experience. And a lovely comment from Catherine key with job crafting is such a helpful concept as someone contemplating a radical career change into psychology this is the perfect inspiration to reflect on my existing work experience with a new lens and help me highlight my relevant skills to a potential employer thank you jack and marianne for introducing me to a really helpful new approach to facilitating a
凯瑟琳，不用谢。在Spotify上，我收到了一些可爱的评论，最近的一条是关于我和凯利·洛夫西（Kelly Lovesey）合作的那期节目，探讨如果你开始一份工作却讨厌它会发生什么。吉娜·阿尔（Gene Al）说：“我现在正处于同样的处境中，对我的问题是文化。新工作才一个月，但真的很难适应那种谁也不跟谁说话的氛围。没有人吃午休，每天还要加班。如果你不这样做，就会觉得有一种无声的评判。感觉这真的不适合我。”拉比·阿隆（Rabby alone）说：“几个月前我辞去了工作，当时我在那只干了几个月，这其中有太多引起了我的共鸣。我真的很喜欢这一集。听到有人谈论这个话题感觉太棒了。”
career change you are so welcome katherine and over on spotify i've had some lovely comments coming through most recently for the episode i did with kelly lovesie about what happened if you start your job and you hate it. Gene Al said, in the same situation now, for me it's the culture, been at a new job for a month but really struggling with the way nobody speaks to each other. No one takes lunch breaks and work overtime daily. Feels like a silent judgment if you don't. It feels like it's not the fit for me. And Rabby alone says I left my job a few months ago after only being there for a couple of months and so much of this resonates with me. I really love this episode. It's so nice hearing someone talk about this topic.
职业转型，不客气，凯瑟琳。在Spotify上，我最近也收到了很多美好的评论，特别是关于我和凯利·洛夫西（Kelly Lovesie）合作的那期节目，探讨如果你入职新工作却发现自己讨厌它会发生什么。吉恩·阿尔（Gene Al）说：“我现在也处于同样的情况，对我来说是文化问题，去了一家新公司一个月，但真的很纠结于那种谁也不理谁的氛围。没有人休午餐休息，每天都在加班。如果你不加班，就会觉得有一种无声的评判。感觉这里真的不适合我。”而拉比·阿隆（Rabby alone）说：“几个月前我辞职了，当时只在那里呆了几个月，这其中的很多内容都引发了我的共鸣。我真的很喜欢这一集。听到有人谈论这个话题感觉太好了。”
You are so welcome, Rabby Alone. So yeah, don't be a stranger. Let me know what you think to this content. And like I said, thank you so much for being here. What would you want the next 100 episodes of the podcast to look like? What guests would you love to learn more about? What topic areas would you love to kind of explore? Do you have an idea you'd like to pitch to the podcast so that you could come on?
不用谢，Rabby Alone。所以，是的，别见外。告诉我你对这些内容有什么看法。就像我说的，非常感谢你的到来。你希望播客接下来的 100 期节目是什么样的？你最想了解哪些嘉宾？你希望探讨哪些主题领域？你有什么想法想向播客推荐，以便你能作为嘉宾上节目吗？
Do let me know. Come and follow me on socials where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective Book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next step in your career, do check out the aspiring psychologist membership and the Ready to Rise program. Don't forget to grab your free psychology success guide by heading to my website, www.Aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com. Thank you again from the bottom of my heart for being here. Please do follow the show.
请告诉我。快来社交媒体上关注我吧，我在各平台的用户名都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。请查看《Aspiring Psychologist Collective Book》和《Clinical Psychologist Collective book》。如果时机成熟，你准备好开启职业生涯的下一步，请查看 aspiring psychologist 会员计划和 Ready to Rise 项目。别忘了访问我的网站 www.Aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com 获取你的免费心理学成功指南。再次由衷地感谢你的到来。请关注本节目。
Please do subscribe to the show. Don't be a stranger. Comment, like. Share your favorite episodes with your friends. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast, that's your side. You'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the aspiring psychologist podcast.
请订阅本节目。别见外。评论、点赞。与你的朋友分享你最喜欢的单集。如果你正准备成为一名心理学家，就让它成为你的指南吧。有这个播客在你身边，你将顺利获得资格。这就是 Aspiring Psychologist 播客。
enter is Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctor at this year, that's okay. I think the most
大家好，我叫 Emily。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士研究生。我买了《Clinical Psychologist Collective book》这本书来帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的心路历程非常有启发性，这让我对自己的心路历程和技能进行了很多反思。它还帮助我摆正心态，提醒我如果今年没有考上博士也没关系。我认为最
unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
意想不到的快乐，然而，是每个人的心路历程都是如此具有启发性。每天把这些故事作为早晨的动力真是一种享受。我几乎舍不得读到结尾。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。